all right we are gonna talk spoilers
what do you mean I just thought oh my
god the viewer part of my brain leaped
for joy I mean they were swapping my
reaction can I say this was yeah I was
so overwhelmed I was overwhelmed I being
the executive producer I kind of know
about the ending before I actually read
it so when I heard about the hinting I
thought it made a lot of sense I thought
it was surprising heartbreaking and and
then I and then I went and tried to make
it even worse as I usually do what we've
really been waiting for for three
seasons and they're doing it I've been
waiting for us to really wasn't really
resistant we had to do all of the
legwork to get us there and now we're
there and it was like keep pushing let's
really really see what the resistance
can do it's a great finale what I love
is Jun's efforts to get all these
important young people out that finally
the waterfords or certainly Fred ends up
getting what he deserves and that's
really hope that they they give it to in
big time I think Fred and Serena
certainly have a lot of stuff to work
out in their marriage I can assure you
what mrs. what if it did was far beyond
the laws of gilja
and the loss of God when you saw that
the two of them turn on each other what
did you think well I love that because
there's a just before that moment
there's a real feeling certainly for
Fred that his wife has connected back
with him so to be deceived was I think a
big smack in the face but you know as as
it should happen to all war criminals
they should definitely get their
comeuppance I have come to deliver them
from the hand of evil men and to lead my
people out of that sorrowful place
[Music]
to a land flowing with milk and honey
how does June come back from everything
that goes down in those final two
episodes I don't know my feeling is if
she's alive at the end of it episode
we're in pretty good shape at the
beginning of the show I was just shocked
that she made it through each episode
alive and now she seems to be making it
through episodes and getting stuff done
so I don't count her out she's she's a
survivor it's she's sticking around for
Hannah for Nick for both twofer I'm
sticking around for Hannah yeah Jun is
still back in Gilead with aunt Lydia
work to do
oh yeah got a few lessons to teach her
watch yourself you got it
there's no handmade style without Jude
in Gilead we realized that she has to be
there but it was so close and there were
different incarnations of her but if she
was going to make it if she wasn't
I feel like now she is because she's
like everyone is gone she has more of a
fire and a fight to get Hannah and get
out
Frieda
don't beat up in Canada all of June's
peeps are in Canada together now without
her I'm like the only one left everyone
left it together
[Music]
we're all connected now all of our
characters I meet Luke and I need Alexei
Sayles character and so I hope that
we're gonna have a gang and try to
smuggle her out on our end what is your
message to the fans after they see this
finale what is my message to the fans
June never gives up and she never gives
up on what she wants and she never gets
gives up on Hanna and so I think I
always ask the audience to not give up
on her
[Music]